jubilation and relief among both the
social democrat rank-and-file and the
party's leadership the result of the
referendum shows overwhelming support
for a grand coalition more than
three-quarters voted in favor and 643
voted yes and fitzy 55.96 percent the
result is a victory for party head Sigma
Gabrielle he is the one who decided to
ask members to vote on the coalition in
a referendum many said this was a risky
move some SPD members were skeptical
about joining forces with Merkel's CDU
and the vote could well have gone
against him but Gabrielle's Gamble has
paid off as wine fest in up this was a
celebration of inner party democracy it
was a celebration of democracy itself I
believe this day will not only go down
in the history of the German Social
Democrats table also go down in the
history of German democracy and
Deutschland and in the referendum was
not only a first in the history of the
party it was also a logistical challenge
hundreds of volunteers here in Berlin
spent the night counting more than 300
thousand postal votes sent in from
around the country but the biggest
challenge is yet to come the SPD has
said yes to joining the new government
next week they have to get down to the
business of running the country